[Musique]
José Legault Émilie Nicolas
a réussi à apaiser la mauvaise humeur la
grogne la frustration appelée ça comme
vous voulez de son cocus de la région de
Québec on va on va écouter ensemble
quelques extraits avant après puis on
revient tout de suite
c'est ce qu'on fait généralement quand
on tient pas nos promesses on dit aux
gens ben écoute je te le rendre je t'en
dois une options
[Musique]
de discussion et on s'appelle tous comme
quoi que c'est à dire la communication
entre nous est essentielle ça a été vite
mais ça met pas en question la décision
qui a été prise sur les bases de
pragmatisme responsabilité mais vous
auriez aimé être consulté définitivement
oui mais on l'a mentionné on a
clairement dit que pour avoir certaines
méthodes de communication puis on était
très clair puis ici on est une famille
je vois pas sortir de la famille parce
qu'on a une chicane de famille
et puis c'est ceux qu'on continue de
recevoir beaucoup de commentaires
beaucoup de colère de la part de nos
concitoyens alors il faut gérer ça et
moi je ne retire absolument à rien de ce
que je vous ai dit la semaine passée
peut-être avec un petit peu moins
d'émotions non non non parce que
honnêtement moi j'ai du travail à faire
comme député de Lévis moi je vais
travailler d'ici 2026 pour que le lien
de centre-ville à centre-ville se fasse
écouter pour ce qui est des enjeux de
communication de consultation à
l'interne on va garder ça à l'intérieur
ça c'est sûr la forme si je puis dire la
façon dont s'est annoncé au député ils
ont été ou pas mis dans le coup le fond
on est énerviendra monsieur Legault a
dit c'est ma décision je la prends je
l'assume entièrement mais premier tour
de table José je commence avec vous sur
ce caucus qui en avait long à dire à
leur patron on imagine
non non mais c'est clair il y a dû avoir
des questions quand même assez pénibles
qui ont été posées au Premier ministre
en tout respect
tout particulièrement je pense c'est
pourquoi est-ce que
cette décision là d'annuler le tunnel
autoroutier là en Québec et Libye ses
prix sans eux et ça ça reste le grand
mystère dans toute cette histoire là
d'où leur incapacité à se préparer
eux-mêmes à l'annonce à préparer aussi
l'opinion autour d'eux d'où l'effet de
choc la semaine dernière et tout coule
de ça ou découle de ça depuis ce
temps-là
et ça ils sont les seuls à savoir
qu'elle a été sa réponse évidemment
Émilie bon aux sorties et puis on en a
présenté quelques-unes les gens disaient
bon évidemment on va pas claquer la
porte de la famille etc mais on sent
quand même que ça ça secoué profondément
une certaine confiance de ce focus de la
région de Québec
tout à fait après le fait que la
confiance soit secoué que personne
envisage claquer la porte je pense que
c'est en dit long surtout sur la culture
politique à laka qui est quand même un
nouveau parti qu'on qu'on apprend à
connaître parce qu'il est au pouvoir
mais en terme de structure militante
c'est un parti qui a été créé par
François Legault comme tel c'est un
parti qui se définit surtout comme
pragmatique il y a pas des clivages
biologiques extrêmement nette à
l'intérieur de ce parti-là donc il y a
pas une structure militante non plus qui
qui
se compare à celle par exemple au niveau
du Parti québécois ou de Québec
solidaire du tout ça contribue à ce que
bon c'est sûr que ça brasse les gens
veulent se parler mais j'essaie
d'imaginer si quelque chose comme ça
s'était passé dans un autre parti
politique il me semble que les
conséquences des conséquences en termes
d'action ont été plus grandes
donc c'est assez fascinant de ce point
de vue là ce qui est en train de se
passer en ce moment pour en fait tester
le contrôle que François degault a sur
son bébé qui finalement la
et puis on voit on voit ce que ça donne
même si les gens sont fâchés pour
l'instant il y a personne qui agit
au-delà d'être franchir par les hommes
madame Marois on peut remonter à
Monsieur l'évêque pour des questions
plus existentielles mais madame Marois
le tutoriel l'amphithéâtre etc c'est
bastien Bavay est-ce que Monsieur LEGO a
réussi l'opération
on remet la couverte un peu là dessus
puis on continue bon ce qu'on me raconte
pour la Réunion en tant que telle c'est
que tout le monde ou à peu près s'est
exprimé dans la Réunion et
essentiellement François Legault a
écouté
ericare est un des seuls à ne pas s'être
exprimé quelqu'un me dit il est gelé
mais je l'ai dans le sens sous le choc
incapable d'exprimer ses émotions donc
ça a été
Erika ne s'est pas exprimé pendant la
réunion Geneviève Dubeau non plus parce
qu'elle est la pâteuse du dossier et
tous ceux qui se sont exprimés selon ce
que je comprends avec des reproches à
faire donc il y a pas eu de ton
complaisant ça a pas été agressif mais
ça a été ferme envers monsieur Legault
et quand dans l'extrait que vous passez
monsieur Legault dit on va garder les
affaires de communication interne à
l'interne ma compréhension c'est que il
y a une chose une seule chose que
François Legault admise devant ses
députés de la région de Québec c'est un
problème de communication c'est à dire
que ils auraient dû être mis dans le
coup plus rapidement les ministres
auraient dû être mis dans le coup plus
rapidement aussi on aurait pu avoir une
espèce de stratégie de communication un
peu meilleur que celle de Geneviève
Guilbaud qui un jour dit c'est à cause
de la chalandage que on fait pas le
projet de Troisième Guerre autoroutier
puis le lendemain on apprend dans des
études que et les contredites par ces
études qui disent qu'il faut pas se
baser sur l'année de référence 2022 bref
ça a été beaucoup ça semble-t-il les
problèmes de communication le fait que
les députés n'aient pas été mis dans le
coup plus rapidement et qu'ils aient été
mis d'un coup pour devant un fait
accompli qu'un jour ils étaient pleines
dans le tunnel avec monsieur Legault
coûte que coûte puis que le lendemain on
ferme l'interrupteur puis on disait on
le fera juste pas le projet ce pont là
entre les deux était incompréhensible
pour beaucoup de députés pour beaucoup
oui
si je peux c'est c'est bien de ce que le
premier ministre positionne ça
précisément comme un problème de
communication mais c'est plus profond
que ça quand même si ce n'était que ça
je pense pas qu'on aurait assisté à
cette espèce de de blessure parce qu'on
peut dire qu'il y a des ministres il y a
des élus qui sont blessés de de cette
expérience là c'est ça remet en question
aussi le module operaldi du bureau du
Premier ministre et comment on gouverne
à la CAQ alors que on se méfie de ses
adversaires ça va c'est tout à fait
normal à la dynamique politique c'est la
nature de la bête mais que on se limite
à une personne Geneviève Guilbaud
d'après ce qu'on a assez vice-première
ministre ministre des Transports qui
elle était dans le secret des dieux a
participé supposément à la prise de
décision ben ça c'est clair que le
premier ministre devoir revoir ça et ça
c'est beaucoup plus profond qu'un simple
problème de communication dans la
profondeur aussi il y a quelqu'un qui me
disait nos commettons nos concitoyens
quand on les rencontre des fois ils sont
pas contents des décisions comprendre
mais là c'est comme plus profond plus
fondamental plus viscéral c'est à dire
que il nous reproche de la revoir monter
un bateau avec le troisième et un enjeu
de crédibilité ici entre le député et
ses concitoyens en particulier dans la
région de Québec exactement
ce que reproche même les gens qui
étaient contre en disant vous aviez le
droit de présenter un projet de
troisième lien mais il y aurait
peut-être fallu que vous l'étayez
davantage parce que là on se retrouve
est-ce que on aura confiance la
prochaine fois puis ça va m'amener tout
à l'heure à l'autre extrait sur le
prochain projet il y a des députés qui
croient pas beaucoup j'ai l'impression à
midi
non effectivement après je pense que la
réflexion plus large aussi que la ville
de Québec est une des villes avec le
plus de kilomètres d'autoroute par
Capital je pense qu'on est seulement 2e
après après carglerie c'est parce que
promettent des bouts de route pour
gagner les élections c'est la région on
a vu beaucoup de ça je pense que à la
longue ça vient de nourrir un cynisme je
pense que c'est important c'est
important de nommer puis de remettre
dans un contexte c'est vraiment pas le
premier projet qui arrive comme ça où
les gens font des promesses pour la
région parce que c'est des compter
toujours qui sont très peu passer d'une
main à l'autre assez rapidement mais
l'autre l'autre élément je pense qui est
important pour comprendre la pression
politique et sur les députés c'est que
on a dit beaucoup que le projet
troisièmement avait été porté par la
Chambre des commerces de Vivy mais c'est
aussi un projet qui était porté par les
radios puis ce que ça crée quand il y a
une stratégie communication qui est
portée encore cette semaine d'ailleurs
beaucoup par des radios qui mettent
aussi la pression sur
Eric sur Erica qui sont très proches et
régulièrement et tout ça est-ce que ça
crée c'est que les gens qui sont pas
contents sont très très vocaux et ça ça
met une pression sur les sur les élus
qui est très particulière c'est pas vrai
que tout le monde dans la région de
Québec et pour le troisième lien à
Québec même particulièrement il y a de
la division le maire lui-même a été élu
à Québec en étant pas particulièrement
pour ce projet de loi de ce projet-là
donc c'est pas tout le monde au Québec
qui est pour ça mais les gens qui sont
pauvres sont mobilisés notamment par ces
stratégies communication là et ça crée
une pression politique sur les élus qui
pense peut-être que c'est tout le monde
mais il reçoit des courriels
particulièrement fâchés Douala comme si
la vie des gens dépendait c'est un peu
sans commune mesure avec la réalité dans
ce sens on va écouter l'opposition en
chambre qui n'allait pas lâcher
aujourd'hui ce sujet et monsieur Legault
ce qui résume un peu sa décision
j'aimerais que François Legault
reconnaisse que c'est une promesse qui
est brisée et s'excuse au Québécois
maintenant une fois que j'ai dit ça une
fois que les excuses qui est le strict
minimum soit prononcé par François
Legault ça change pas qu'on a perdu 5
ans pour lutter face à l'enjeu de la
mobilité dans la grande région de Québec
François logo des questions à répondre
maintenant il doit s'expliquer au
Québécois et au Québécois parce qu'il
les a amenés en bateau pendant des
années avec un projet insensé que jamais
été rien d'autre au fond qu'un slogan
devant un bride contrat le bride du
contrat de démocratique à savoir que
lorsqu'on prend un engagement
solennellement pour le répète à
plusieurs reprises on peut pas faire
exactement l'inverse
je comprends là qu'il y a une forte
réaction dans population mais en même
temps
un bout de ligne c'est moi qui prend la
décision c'est moi qui a pris la
décision et je l'assume je comprends la
déception mais ma responsabilité c'est
avec les nouvelles données de prendre la
meilleure décision pour les Québécois et
c'est ce que je fais puis donc je
m'excuserai pas de prendre la meilleure
décision pour les Québécois
on
va le faire
voilà
ce qui ce qui fait qu'on en parle autant
parce que des gens ont dit oui mais
c'est normal que devant des faits qui
changent ils changent mais ils étaient
tellement convaincus qu'ils aient-il ou
pas étude on va y aller c'était pas il y
a 4 ans il y a 7 mois Sébastien Beauvais
lors de la campagne électorale et bien
sûr que nous on en a beaucoup pas nous
étant les médias on a beaucoup parlé ça
crée une boule de neige énorme voilà et
le problème de François Legault dans ce
dossier là et de ses ministres c'est
qu'ils ont beau vouloir essayer
d'expliquer sur la base des études puis
des études qui disent pas tout toujours
ce qu'ils veulent exactement dire les
politiciens la raison pour laquelle ils
ont fermé l'interrupteur sur le projet
le problème c'est pas nécessairement ça
c'est peut-être la bonne décision qui
prennent ça va coûter trop cher les
données sont pas au rendez-vous et ainsi
de suite le problème c'est le décalage
entre ce qui nous disent maintenant et
ce qui nous disait avant pas plus tard
qu'en campagne électorale on va le faire
coûte que coûte ça va être une décision
politique on n'a pas besoin d'études on
sait qu'on en a besoin
les études ont démontré en tout cas
selon le gouvernement que on en avait
pas nécessairement besoin et donc c'est
ce décalage là entre le plein gaz
l'appui convaincu s'en nuance au projet
il y a à peine quelques mois et la
situation qu'on vit aujourd'hui ce qui
sème le doute est-ce que c'était juste
pour avoir des votes dans la grande
région de Québec qu'on a fait deux trois
élections avec ce projet-là tout en
sachant un moment donné que ça coûterait
beaucoup trop beaucoup trop cher puis on
n'a pas osé le dire plus rapidement au
Québec parce qu'on offrait l'occasion de
le dire encore une fois en campagne en
disant oui mais ne serait-ce que ce ne
serait pas plus prudent d'attendre des
études avant de vous engager à plein gaz
etc bon Émilie José conclusion sur les
explications sur le fond donc José
c'était vraiment intéressant de voir la
stratégie des parties de position bouger
dans les derniers 48 heures quand même
de manière assez importante alors ils
ont commencé par cibler ericare qui
était qui est vraiment une cible facile
c'est le maillon le plus faible c'est
lui qui avait mis son siège un jeu il y
a les spatch Canada
il démissionne pas bon alors c'est sûr
que ça en a fait une première cible très
commode et pour iridienne c'est loin
d'être terminé il est loin d'en avoir
terminé avec avec Erica mais aujourd'hui
les chefs de parties d'opposition sont
allés sur un autre sujet ils sont là
tout à coup ils ont visé François
Legault lui-même et le doute a été semé
en effet mais là le doute envers le
Premier ministre c'est pas sur n'importe
quel plat son authenticité sa sincérité
est-ce qu'un effet il aurait su avant la
campagne électorale que ce projet-là n'a
pas debout comme plusieurs experts de
toute manière le 10 depuis des années
alors c'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont
attendu un petit 24 heures avant de
viser le Premier ministre directement et
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait et là on va
voir évidemment combien de temps ça peut
ça peut durer mais monsieur Legault est
encore très solide dans l'opinion
publique oui
tout à fait on va écouter justement pour
faire suite à ce que vous venez dire un
extrait un monsieur Legault solide mais
vous allez vous rendre compte quand même
un peu choqué qui répond à une question
de Paul Saint-Pierre plat Mondon puis il
y avait moins envie de rire on écoute
tout ça les change
est-ce que le premier ministre peut
reconnaître que l'élection 2022
particulièrement à Québec qui est dans
chaudière à palaches a été faite sur la
base de fausses représentation
une personne sur les 125 ici devrait pas
poser ce genre de questions c'est le
député de Camille Laurent
si demain matin il y avait une élection
dans Camille Laurin
sans
vol de dépliant du véhicule
est-ce que le député de Camille Laurens
serait le député qui est ici devant nous
aujourd'hui
Sébastien monsieur Legault
contre-attaque comme ça c'est qu'il est
quoi il est touché et il a une mauvaise
journée puis ça a mal commencé ce matin
il s'est fait parler dans le casque avec
excusez moi l'expression par ses députés
de la région de Québec et c'est
poursuivi c'est totalement gratuit c'est
à dire que on peut pas mettre en doute
la légitimité de l'élection de Paul
saint-pierre-près-monde oui il y a eu un
événement probablement qui ont fait de
l'analyse politique ça a contribué à son
élection ce qui s'est passé dans ses
circonscription mais on peut pas mettre
en doute la légitimité de son poste de
député et quand François Hugo tombe à ce
niveau-là d'attaque quand il se fait
poser une question sur le troisième lien
qui répond quelque chose de totalement
farfelu c'est parce qu'il a une mauvaise
journée et puis parce qu'il est un peu
désarçonné
il est à sa deuxième majorité je le
disais tout à l'heure il y a fondé son
parti donc sur lequel il trône et sur
lequel il y a tout il contrôle toutes
les cordes il a été premier ministre
durant une pandémie ou en plus il y
avait pratiquement je dirais on est dans
les mesures d'urgence ou
l'opposition avait pas les pouvoirs
qu'il y avait et là il se fait il se
fait critiquer par son propre parti les
gens dans une région qui va beaucoup
kakis sont pas confort contre lui il y a
pas l'habitude c'est pas quelqu'un qui
réagit bien devant la critique c'est
quelqu'un qui a un tempérament impatient
qu'on a vu déjà sur d'autres dossiers
notamment lorsqu'il était question des
syndicats et quelques semaines dans ce
secteur de la santé donc c'est ça qui
ressort et c'est pas la première fois je
pense que ça ressort mais c'est ce qui
est ça
oui tout à fait mais il y a aussi ce
sentiment classique des gouvernements
qui sont relus je dirais tu devrais dire
des premiers ministres des gouvernements
qui sont réunis pour un deuxième mandat
plus fort que le premier on a vu ça avec
un élève on a vu ça avec un verre on
dirait qu'il y a une espèce de sentiment
d'investibulité qui les habite et ça
devient difficile aussi et donc la
critique devient encore plus difficile à
prendre pour eux à cause de ça et il
faut faire attention parce que je dis
pas que c'est ce qui va arriver à la CAQ
mais si on regarde ce qui s'est passé
avec monsieur Lévesque avec Monsieur
Bourassa dans ce sentiment
d'intervincible ils ont vécu des
deuxième mandats qui ont été assez
difficiles merci beaucoup contrairement
à leurs sentiments au début du deuxième
mandat parce qu'il était plus fort que
le premier donc encore une fois je dis
pas que c'est ce qui va se passer je
pense qu'il faut observer aussi ce
phénomène là et ça ça devrait à lui-même
un petit voyage en jaune aussi de sur le
tableau de bord du gouvernement mais il
y en a à l'interne qui se demande si cet
événement là du troisième bien est pas
comme une première fissure dans le
téflon parce que il est passé à travers
des crises puis il y a bien survécu mais
là est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose de
profond vis-à-vis de la crédibilité de
ce gouvernement qui pourrait écorcher le
téflon il y en a qui se posent la
question on n'a pas la réponse mais il y
en a qui pose la question ce qui
illustre bien ça c'est quand je on pose
la question par exemple à martine Biron
tout à l'heure en lui demandant le
troisième lien avec le transport en
commun vous puis là sa réponse est très
claire telle on attend les détails puis
on verra avant de s'engager
contrairement à Bernard drinville qui
dit je veux voir presque des pelles
avant 2026 elle a dit regardez là on
attend les détails avant que moi j'aille
faire du porte-à-porte puis promettre ça
aux gens on a eu cette impression là
Sébastien tout à l'heure là
il rejoue dans le film on va le faire on
va le faire à tout prix puis il faut que
ce soit parti en 2026 va-t-en pas là
Bernard apprends à me donner
c'est incroyable c'est c'est c'est
l'autre clip à préserver ça après celui
de Monsieur Erika qui disait j'aime
aussi les enjeux enregistrer moi merci à
vous trois bonne soirée au revoir